say the line here's some new sunscreen
reviews yeah
it's michelle vlad muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic ms and sunscreen
connoisseur star korean asked me to
review a bunch of popular korean
sunscreens for this sponsored video
because most of you are heading into
summer in the northern hemisphere and
they've kindly put all of the sunscreens
i'm talking about today on sale all the
links are in the description if you want
to check them out conveniently i'm
heading out of summer so i've actually
been trying out tons of sunscreens and
there are some really nice ones in this
batch including a few that you've
probably seen hyped up tons on social
media i firmly believe that there is the
perfect sunscreen out there for everyone
but it can be a bit of a journey to get
there my top tips for buying sunscreens
that you will probably enjoy are firstly
check out reviews from people with a
similar skin type as yours my skin is
oily and dehydration prone and also
pretty prone to clogged pores and
hyperpigmentation if your skin is
similar there is a good chance that
we'll like similar sunscreens and
probably similar skin care products in
general tip number two i really
recommend writing down a list of
sunscreen needs and wants and every time
you come across a sunscreen that sounds
good check it against every item on that
list this is a really good way of making
sure you don't get swept up in the hype
and completely forget about a massive
deal breaker if you don't like the way a
sunscreen feels on your face then don't
forget that you can use it up on your
neck your hands and the rest of your
body i think our skincare nurse tend to
forget about everything below about here
so
it is a good way to show some love to
the poor neglected areas i also made a
video recently answering all of the
common questions that i get about
sunscreens so make sure you check that
video out as well on to our sunscreens
i'm going to start with my favorite
because i am not good at keeping the
good things until the end the beauty of
chosen relieves sunrise and probiotics
this is the sunscreen that's spf 50 plus
and pa with four pluses which is as high
as you can go for spf and uva protection
in korea the spf rating has been
certified by two separate labs in korea
and spain testing in two different labs
in two different countries was one of
the ways i recommended for getting a
reliable spf rating in my video on the
spf apocalypse of late 2020
so it's nice to see this being done and
this info being shared publicly this
sunscreen is made by colmar a big
sunscreen manufacturer in korea that has
a great reputation for making really
effective sunscreens in fact all four of
the sunscreens i'm talking about today
are manufactured by colmar they've
become really popular post spf pocalypse
i think a lot of brands have become
rightfully nervous about their sunscreen
formulations which makes perfect sense
all four sunscreens are also actually
approved and sold as uv protective
sunscreen functional cosmetics in korea
although they're not approved in the us
or australia or a bunch of other
countries adil manila talks a lot about
the korean beauty industry on her
channel and to make sure your korean
sunscreen is actually approved in korea
she recommends checking two things
firstly that the term functional
cosmetic shows up on both the tube and
on the box of the sunscreen secondly
that it's actually sold in korea so for
example you can look up the korean
website of the brand and check that it's
available there i've checked this for
all four of the sunscreens i'm talking
about today out of them the beauty of
chosen sunscreen is my favorite this is
a chemical sunscreen with newer filters
and it has a very nice light texture
like a hydrating gel moisturizer it's
not greasy at all it sinks into skin
very quickly and it is very hydrating
this sunscreen has very little white
cast it doesn't show up on glow by
ramone who has medium-ish brown skin but
it can show up on moderately darker skin
tones like glow skin guys even though it
is a chemical or organic sunscreen it
has mbbt in it which is an insoluble
organic filter and those solid particles
can sometimes give a white cast on skin
that's on the darker side it has no
fragrance and no alcohol if those are
problems for your skin and it's designed
to be super cosmetically elegant and it
works really well under makeup it's also
designed to wash off easily which is
great if you're worried about clogged
pores
but it does mean that it's not going to
stay nicely spread out on your skin if
you're sweating or moving around a lot
so keep that in mind when you use it the
key skincare ingredient in here is rice
which is a pretty popular ingredient in
korean skin care it's meant to be great
for hydration and for sensitive skin the
packaging says it has 30 rice extract
and a thousand parts per million rice
germ extract as well as three probiotic
rice ferments there are also a bunch of
other plant extracts in there as well
along with niacinamide which is great
for soothing skin and helping with
brightening there's also glycerin which
is an incredible hydrating humectant
which is one of my favorites
and adenosine which is an anti-wrinkle
active beauty of choson has some other
products that i really like as well they
have a great cleansing balm and a bunch
of nice serums with a mix of traditional
korean hanbang ingredients like ginseng
rice propolis as well as more modern
ingredients like niacinamide and snail
mucin i recommend checking them out if
you're in the market for some new
products mary and may sicker soothing
sun cream is next and this seems to be a
very similar formula to the beauty of
chosen sunscreen it has the same
sunscreen actives and base ingredients
in a similar order but different
skincare ingredients and a touch of
fragrance meri mei is a brand i haven't
heard of before but they're a clean
korean brand with a core brand
philosophy of being 16 free and using
only ewg green grade ingredients ewg
green grade seems to be a pretty common
claim for korean products now i'm
guessing what it means is that all of
the ingredients are rated at three or
below in the ewg's completely
unscientific and pretty done arbitrary
rating system
i've talked about why clean beauty is bs
before in this video anyway as you'd
expect this has a very similar texture
to the beauty of chosen sunscreen the
differences are mostly with the skincare
ingredients as well as a light slightly
floral fragrance that goes away pretty
quickly after you apply it it's been
tested to be hypoallergenic and like the
beauty of chosen sunscreen it's
formulated to work really well under
makeup as an everyday commuter sunscreen
in terms of the skincare ingredients the
beauty of chosen sunscreen focuses on
rice whereas this focuses on centella
which you probably guessed from the
slicker name centella is great for
soothing sensitive skin i love using
sicker products when my skin is
irritated and needs a bit of nourishment
this sun cream has 10 000 parts per
million or one percent f thicker complex
which has seven different centella
extracts and fermented yeast it's meant
to be soothing and hydrating it also has
niacinamide and adenosine which is why
this is also a whitening and anti-aging
functional cosmetic in korea on top of
being a sunscreen i talked about this
ingredient pairing before in my hamish
video the beauty of chosen sunscreen has
this niacinamide and adenosine pairing
too but it doesn't have this extra
functional cosmetic claim i'm not sure
why but it could explain why the meriam
may sunscreen has a higher regular
retail price next up we have the isentry
hyaluronic acid watery sun gel i've
talked about this before this is a
chemical or organic sunscreen with a
relatively heavier texture compared to a
lot of korean sunscreens it's super
popular it has no white cast no
fragrance and no alcohol and it's
recommended for dry and sensitive skin
like the other two it's spf 50 plus and
pa with four pluses and also like a lot
of other korean sunscreens now they have
the independent testing on their site to
verify these ratings and this one has it
from the korean institute of
dermatological science this is also
proved as a whitening and anti-wrinkle
functional cosmetic again because it's
got that niacinamide and adenosine combo
on top of that this also has eight types
of hyaluronic acid hyaluronic acid is
used in skin care as a humectant that
grabs onto water and keeps it on and in
your skin but a lot of people complain
that it can feel like it dries your skin
out i think this is because a lot of
products use only one size of hyaluronic
acid so it all might stay on the surface
of your skin and it feels like it dries
into a film to avoid these a lot of
products including this one now use a
range of sizes of hyaluronic acid to
hydrate your skin at different depths so
it feels a bit more like well-rounded
hydration there are a bunch of other
skincare ingredients in this as well
like astaxanthin cintella and ceramide
the isn't free website recommends this
for outdoor activities but it isn't
officially water resistant so i don't
think you should rely on this for like
hardcore exercise but i do think it is
probably going to hold up better to
movement and sweat compared to your
average korean sunscreen this is also
recommended for reapplication over
makeup which i've talked about before i
recommend using a cushion puff sponge
for this it's also been tested for skin
irritation and it passed with flying
colors unfortunately on their page they
also show ewg ratings for every
ingredient in it which i thought we
moved past as a species as well as the
sunscreen infographic that's not quite
right it says chemical sunscreens need
30 minutes to absorb before working
which is a bit silly because it's not
true and this is a chemical sunscreen so
they're pointing out a fake disadvantage
for their own product they also show a
video of it absorbing uv immediately
under uv camera so yeah don't think that
chemical sunscreens need a longer
waiting time they have the same waiting
time as a physical sunscreen you just
need it to dry down and form a nice
continuous layer that doesn't move
around too much before you go out into
the sun i quite like the sunscreen even
though it's recommended for sensitive
and dry skin and my skin is oily isn't
tree also have a stick sunscreen that's
recommended for oily skin that i'm
pretty keen to try as well the last
sunscreen i'm talking about today is the
innisfree intensive long lasting
sunscreen x i had to try that three
times that is a tongue twister i'm
pretty excited about this one because
like the rest of the sunscreens this is
spf 50 plus mpa with four pluses but the
special bit is that it's actually water
resistant it's recommended for surfing
and playing in the water thanks to dilma
not again my korean beauty insider info
guru water resistant in korea means that
the spf drops by less than 20
after 40 minutes in water during that
water resistance test this is less
strict than the australian and the us
standards they need the sunscreen to
stay at the full spf after water
exposure but it is stricter than the one
which lets it drop to half the spf i'm
pretty sure this is the first water
resistant korean sunscreen that i've
ever tried unsurprisingly it is quite
heavy in texture for korean sunscreen
but it is a lot lighter than a typical
western water resistant sunscreen
sunscreens that are water resistant
usually have a lot of polymers and
thicker oilier ingredients to keep it in
place when your skin gets wet so you
usually end up with more of a noticeable
feeling on your face this is a pretty
unique sunscreen in my sunscreen library
it works well for those in between
situations where you might want a
smoother lighter sunscreen that sits
nicely under makeup but you're also
going to get like
a bit moist like maybe you're going on a
boat ride at a wedding or something
i don't know your life i really like
that korea has a standard for their
water resistant label there are a few
japanese sunscreens i've tried that i
really liked that claim to be water
resistant
but unfortunately as far as i know there
isn't a standard for water resistance in
japan so unless the brand describes how
they tested their claim you just don't
really know how much you can rely on
that if you have recommendations for
water resistant korean sunscreens please
leave them in the comments so this is a
combination sunscreen that uses a mix of
both organic and inorganic uv filters it
has a slight white cast that mostly goes
away as the sunscreen settles down i
would expect that this might not be
great for dark skin tones i'm guessing
that white cast is from the zinc oxide
and or the titanium dioxide this
sunscreen doesn't have alcohol in it and
it has a hydrating feel with a slightly
oily finish that's a bit more noticeable
than with other korean sunscreens the
scent is floral and moderately strong
which innisfree says is from a low
allergen fragrance based on the reviews
i found online most people don't have
icing with this but a few people do
ice sting is quite individual and not
everyone gets stinging from the same
products and ingredients so for most
people this is probably fine one last
thing i do have to mention this coral
reef friendly logo because it is on the
front
i am not a fan of this label especially
coming from a product that i'm pretty
sure isn't being sold near any coral
reefs i've talked a lot about this whole
reef safe marketing in previous videos
but the concentrations of sunscreens
that were found to damage corals and
studies so far are well below the
concentrations that have been measured
in the wild the ocean is massive and it
mixes around a lot so sunscreen washing
off into the ocean really doesn't seem
like a big issue compared to
everything else that coral reefs are
facing unless you are basically touching
the coral here it just seems to mean
that it just doesn't have oxybenzone and
octanoxate those are the two ingredients
that were banned in hawaii following a
study that was pushed very heavily in
the media but this sunscreen actually
does have nanozinc oxide and
nanotitanium dioxide which were both
found to damage coal at again
unrealistically high concentrations i
don't think the evidence shows that it's
a real issue for any sunscreen
ingredient but i think if you're a brand
using that in your marketing you should
be
holding it to a consistent standard they
did recently change their packaging to a
white tube without this reef logo so
that's pretty encouraging so keep that
new packaging in mind as well if you
have trouble finding this all of these
sunscreens are on sale at star korean at
the moment the links are in the
description make sure you check them out
if you're looking for a new sunscreen if
you found this video useful click the
like and please consider subscribing and
joining the notification squad also make
sure you check out my other videos on
sunscreen and skincare which should be
popping up next to me now